social media star Logan Paul is
apologizing after fans blasted him for
posting a video of a suicide victim over
the weekend Paul is one of the most
popular people on YouTube he has more
than 15 million subscribers many of them
children in the video which we won't
show in full the 22 year old and his
friends are wandering around a forest in
Japan when they stumble across the
victim we just find a dead person in the
suicide forest hanging so okay a lot of
things going through my mind this is the
first for me this literally probably
just happened the clip from Japan so
called suicide forest near Mount Fuji
includes but includes blurred video of
the victim
you also hear Paul making light of the
situation the clip reportedly was viewed
more than six million times before Paul
took it down he posted an apology on
Twitter calling the video a mistake and
saying his intention was to raise
awareness on suicide quote I'm often
reminded of how big of a reach I truly
have and with great power comes great
responsibility for the first time in my
life I'm regretful to say I handled that
power incorrectly it won't happen again